[Music]
when stocks take a steep drop investors
can come face to face
with a bear market this is one they
encountered in march 2020. it's been
fierce and fast and ferocious the
selling has been and that's what really
has caught everyone off guard bear
markets tell you that the stock market
has fallen quite a bit and it's an
indicator
that major indexes are significantly off
their highs and it's a sign that people
are pretty fearful about the market
right now but just like facing an actual
bear some analysts say the best thing to
do when a bear market is approaching is
to stay calm and not make any sudden
moves here's how markets make their way
into bear territory and what has helped
turn them around in the past
stocks enter a bear market when they
lose at least 20 percent of their value
from a recent high let's look back at
the 2020 chart you can see when the
market started to fall in february it
entered a bear market here just under a
month later
the term is a shorthand way for wall
street to mark when stocks have taken a
tumble a sign that investors are anxious
about the future and moving away from
risky assets there's a number of things
that can make investors more risk-averse
one they can grow concerned about how
stocks are valued and say is is this
stock really worth what i think it's
worth or worth the premium that i'm
putting on it have valuations run up too
far too fast this was a factor in a bear
market in 2001 when a bursting market
bubble drove down stock values i believe
i was asked about the markets today i'm
i'm sorry people are losing value in
their portfolios
another really important factor is the
economy often bear markets have been
affiliated with economic recession so
that's one thing that can really put
investors on edge recessions have
accompanied nine of the last 17 bear
markets and while one doesn't
necessarily cause the other problems in
the economy can be a major factor in
bringing stocks down high inflation
contributed to one of the longest bear
markets in history in the 1970s
other things that can lead to bear
markets are big events that threaten
corporate profits for example that drop
in stocks we looked at from 2020 was
caused by the beginning of the
coronavirus pandemic when investors were
anxious about the effect the virus might
have on the economy
often investors start to get concerned
about the levels of uncertainty out
there and they decide it's time for me
to dump stocks that can drive prices
down so to review a bear market occurs
when stocks have dropped by a certain
amount but what turns them around
stock prices depend on a variety of
factors that can change quickly or
slowly
there's the fed there's the economy
there's u.s corporations there's
consumer behavior you have to take into
account all of those things for the bear
market to go back into hibernation
stocks need to rebound by at least 20
percent from their bottom point flipping
into a bull market the s p 500 on
average spends about 142 trading days
from the time it enters a bear market to
the time it exits this chart shows five
recent times the s p 500 went into a
bear market starting from when the
market began to decline to when it made
a full recovery after stocks started
falling in 2000 when the dot-com bubble
burst the index didn't hit bottom for
over a year and a half and it took until
2007 to swing back to where it started
part of the reason that did take so long
to recover was just the sheer magnitude
of the boom in stock prices
which made the bust just so so dramatic
and it took years for us to reclaim
those highs but the 2020 bear market
turned around in a record amount of time
it hit bottom after just 23 trading days
and only took 126 days to swing to a new
high
one of the biggest reasons for the
rebound was the federal reserve and
government stimulus
stimulus checks and lower interest rates
helped increase spending indicating to
investors that companies could make it
through with government support measures
like this also helped bring stocks up in
other bear markets like after the market
crash in the late 2000s though the
recovery happened over a longer period
of time to break the adverse feedback
loop it is essential that we continue to
complement fiscal stimulus with strong
government action to stabilize financial
institutions and financial markets when
the fed steps in to provide more
stimulus historically that's helped the
stock market other things that
economists and analysts say can make
investors more confident and bring up
stock values are corporate growth and
strong employment numbers when people
feel good about spending money or
they're more optimistic about the future
that can drive up stock prices and that
can help the economy but changing
investor sentiment can take a long time
and the recovery can be a difficult
waiting game for many individual
investors holding tight is often the
best path forward historically selling
stocks during bear markets has been a
terrible idea which is to say in the
past bear markets have always turned
around and have sometimes resulted in
high returns for patient investors
but bears
are unpredictable and the next time
stocks take a steep dip it could be
years before investments pay off